people love these Avengers movies they
really do but then Jason Statham was
talking smack about the Avengers
recently and I don't know if you're
aware but he said quote I could take my
grandma and put her in a cape and
they'll put her on a green screen and
it'll have stunt doubles come in and do
all the action anybody can do it
Wow yeah yeah no I heard about this and
I heard the thank you Mark Ruffalo is
very funny about I don't know why
anybody would talk smack about something
you know it's a round world however you
are in your living is is great he's
brilliant at what he does
you know III couldn't do it and it's
true you know there are times when I try
and do as many of the stunts as I can
myself but there are times when it's too
dangerous or it's too tricky and even
the producer says this is too dangerous
and tricky for you and you know
potentially he should maybe think about
investing in like an acting double you
know
I would never talk [ __ ] about somebody
else's you know I'm just saying that you
know I've read the contract they
employed me as an actor you know there's
obviously stuntmen in the world you've
met them you see them yeah they're very
good at what they you know very good at
what they do and let them do it but it's
a really really tricky scene with some
very tricky dialogue one might consider
just you gonna put it out there I hope
you don't run into him yourself I'm bad
but no he's very butch I don't want to
be beat handle him I'll bring I'll bring
a stunt double majors been trying to
drum up work for his grandma